[Music]
you know my story started way back you
know the age of 14 growing up in a drug
infested community i always told myself
junior not going to be that person you
know i'm never going to do that well
let's flash forward it started out as a
gram of cocaine to three ounces a day i
couldn't film i couldn't function i
couldn't do anything damn
all right you know i got busted in macon
county alabama but at that time i kept
using
for another year and they didn't know
what to do and the house i told my
daughter that would always be hers i
sold for a hundred thousand dollars
guess what two months later a hundred
thousand dollars was smoked up in
cocaine
um
i stayed in hotels i had my dope man
staying there i ran out of money um i
started like hustling i used to have
jewelry all my hands it's the only ring
i've got left bracelet that had every
one of my daughter's birthstones on it
and my grandkids um
was no longer
the kids
still look at me as that drug addict
they look at me as i'm still a bad
person
have you had a moment with all of them
where you just apologized for the past
it is hard for me to say i'm sorry
sometimes i'm almost to be honest with
you like there for a while i just
thought that things would go back to
normal like when i got clean you know
sometimes it's hard to say i'm wrong
dealing with that raw emotion sometimes
is hard for me to do
i am sorry for some of the actions that
i made but i do feel like sometimes the
girls
hold my path and what i've done and what
what i may be still doing in a way
they just think that i'm supposed to be
this perfect person and i'm not you know
nobody's i'm perfect
[Music]
you